Donald Trump has a very nationalistic
overall worldview that carries over into
his trade policy he sees these kinds of
things as very much zero-sum in which
one side wins and another side loses
we've lost our jobs like we're a bunch
of babies they've gone to other
countries they've gone to Mexico they've
gone to many other countries it's all so
easy believe me it's all so easy but in
a complex system like global trade it's
not always easy to tell who's winning
Trump has suggested really really really
strongly that he wants to crack down on
imports from Mexico and plants and
factories and everything else going into
Mexico and that is driven down the value
of New Mexico's currency an enormous
amount i rana Clee making the peso
cheaper makes it an even more attractive
place to locate production because it
means that in effect mexican workers are
being paid less and makes it harder for
American factories to compete with
Mexican ones but that's not what Donald
Trump says is going to happen right and
they're gonna say yes sir we're moving
back to the United States we're gonna
build our Factory in the United States
we're not moving to Mexico and we're
gonna create a lot of new employment
Trump blames the loss of manufacturing
jobs on trade deals like NAFTA the North
American Free Trade Agreement that
reduced barriers to trade between the US
Canada and Mexico after will tear down
trade barriers between our three nations
it will create the world's largest trade
zone and create 200,000 jobs in this
country we're not getting anything
we have NAFTA which is a total and
complete disaster while trade deals are
an easy target on the campaign trail
there are only one part of the equation
when you look at the really long term
you can see that manufacturing jobs have
been declining as a share of the economy
very steadily for a very long time and
that tells us that even though trade
deals matter they're not the driver of
this big trend it's just over the long
haul
because of automation as economies
evolve in advance more people work in
the service sector fewer people work in
the manufacturing sector trade plays a
role in that but it's not the primary
driver despite this fact it's exactly
those jobs that Trump is claiming to
protect by withdrawing from the TPP the
trans-pacific partnership this
particular trade deal it was designed to
take a lot of Asian countries and bind
them more closely together with the
United States one reason countries were
eager to do a trade deal with the United
States rather than with China is that
they're closer to China and thus they're
a little bit afraid of China and they
want to keep the United States invested
in Asia if we pull out that may leave
some of these countries feeling exposed
or alone and like they need to enter
into a Chinese economic orbit this
decision means fewer cheap imports but
it also affects the market for American
exports one thing that's worth noting
here is that farmers would have been big
winners under trans-pacific partnership
in particular I think the expectation
was that the United States would be able
to export a lot more agricultural goods
to Japan if the US had joined the TPP
American farmers would have had a
stronger relationship with Japan the
world's fourth largest agricultural
consumer rural voters broke very very
heavily in favor of Donald Trump but
they may actually lose out by his sort
of less trade friendly policies and it
just shows that the world is complicated
and it's difficult to change things and
you really do need to talk to expert
people I'm a free trader a hundred
percent but we need smart people making
the deals and we don't have smart people
making the view from some you is that
for us to win it trade somebody else has
to be losing
this country is going to start winning
again we don't win anymore I don't think
that that's true if he proves me wrong
you know I think he'll have a great deal
to brag about but I think he's gonna
find that you know the forces dragging
American manufacturing employment down
are fairly profound and that the kinds
of things he thinks will fix it are just
as likely to make things worse is better
[Music]